salut la team menthe à l'eau et bon
dimanche pour ce qui regarde la vidéo le
jour de sa sortie pour la première fois
sur la chaîne du mental vlog je vais
vous parler d'un livre de mentalisme
alors je demande un générique salue la
team menthe à l'eau avant de commencer
les résultats du concours pour le guide
de bernard werber sont dans la
description et aujourd'hui je vais vous
parler d'un livre de mentalisme qui est
sûrement le plus important pour moi en
tout cas dans mon parcours en moi c'est
un livre que j'ai extrêmement appréciée
il s'agit de ex nihilo d'angelo stagnaro
on le voit bien la caméra très bonne
idée que je viens d'avoir vous faire
voir l'usb n o si jamais vous avez du
mal à le trouver ce qui va être
forcément le cas vous aurez l'iace ben
c'est plus facile pour faire la
recherche vous la met dans la
description également bon tous confondus
c'est un des livres qui a été le plus
important dans ma vie en tant que
mentalist mais c'est peut-être aussi
parce que c'est au moment où j'ai
rencontré ce livre que c'était plutôt
pas mal avec une petite image qui fait
peur au début
alors je vais vous lire le petit
hystérique qui au tout départ une
analyse du langage du corps de
l'intuition de l'équivoque de
l'interprétation des mouvements
musculaires du charisme de
l'anthropologie culturelle des
statistiques des forces psychologiques
et détours mentalisme automatique de
l'observation de la causalité et du bon
sens
réjouissez-vous en secret de tout ce que
vous savez c'est le plus difficile
y'a marqué ici que c'est la deuxième
partie de la trilogie ouvrage
psychologique j'ai jamais trouvé le
premier ou le troisième je sais même pas
comment ils certaine pour lire ce
bouquin fois quand même être ouvert
d'esprit il ya des choses qui sont un
peu bullshit aujourd'hui là dedans mais
ça permet d'avoir un aperçu très large
et on se dit que c'est d'un tout petit
livret que c'est quand même bizarre que
je dise que ce soit extrêmement large
salle les vous fait voir la taille comme
ça du sommaire il ya l'autre page aussi
de l'autre côté on va retrouver deux
dans des choses pour déchiffrer l'autre
les observations médicales des résumés
général des comportements
l'interprétation des mouvements
musculaires des chaussures l'équivoque
des choses sur des forces psychologiques
des repères mnémotechnique choses très
intéressantes que j'ai pas vu dans
beaucoup de bouquins il ya la
philosophie du mentalisme les problèmes
d'éthique les mises en garde
il parle de choses très large comme
l'effet barnum que vous êtes nombreux je
crois connaître et ya cette définition
que j'aime beaucoup aussi un moment
donné qui est un illusionniste essai de
dupes et l'oeil un ventriloque essai de
dupes et l'oreille est un mentaliste
essai de dupes et l'esprit c'est
intéressant ça vient on y retrouve une
bibliographie extrêmement riche pour
ceux qui parlent anglais
alors là c'est magique pour vous mais
vous allez aussi à trouver des
références à des livres en français même
si je vous dis c'est quand même assez
rare au niveau du contenu on est
vraiment sur le déchiffrage de l'autre
la lecture de l'autre et aussi sur des
choses d' influence c'est vraiment un
livre conseil crcc pas extrêmement fun à
lire par contre l'auteur vous parle à
vous directement et vous donne des
conseils à vous d'avoir l'esprit
critique aussi le sens critique pour
savoir ce qui est bon pour vous comme
conseil ou pas il parle de ses
recherches il parle de sa propre
expérience il parle de ses propres
conclusions
mais soyons clairs c'est pas un livre
pour se marrer mais pour autant il n'est
pas difficile à dire il est vraiment
accessible à tout le monde
après c'est comme tous les livres lire
c'est bien après s'entraîner et appliqué
et retenir c'est autre chose et c'est
une vraie volonté de travail qu'il faut
derrière le livre en lui-même il fera
rien à part vous amener un petit peu de
connaissance élargie par contre si vous
mettez à prendre quatre dents a essayé
de le retenir et encore mieux à
l'appliquer alors c'est un vrai bon
premier pas vers le mentalisme mais le
petit reproche à faire vers le
mentalisme cibles en même temps non je
fais un reproche non c'est dégueulasse
je vais pas faire de reproche parce
qu'il a quand même marqué ici en gros
guide du corps wedding ya pas marqué on
va devoir tout ce qui fait partie du
mentalisme donc ouais c'est vraiment
quand même plus ciblée sur la lecture et
l'interprétation des personnes mais ça
ouvre un petit peu vers autre chose et
ça reste quand même un bon point de
départ
je vais essayer de trouver des liens
internet pour vous le procurer je vous
mettrai dans la description si on n'a
pas ce sera simplement que j'en ai pas
trouvés et dans ces cas là je vous
conseille d'aller dans vos librairies
habituel avec le numéro d'isbn que je
vous mets et d'aller leur demander s'ils
peuvent en commande et puisque vous êtes
là et qu'on est dimanche et que je suis
tranquillement assis avant même que le
soleil ne se soit levé je vous donner
quelques petites infos supplémentaires
l'info par exemple de la vidéo demain
elle va parler de la théorie du yes
c'est comme dans le film yes man connais
quelqu'un qui a fait ça durant 30 jours
et on va en parler ensemble sur la
chaîne c'est vraiment intéressant
d'avoir le retour de quelqu'un qui l'a
fait toujours dans la vidéo je sais que
j'ai pas encore fait la vidéo du my maps
mais elle me prend beaucoup de temps à
faire et je veux pas gâcher parce que
vous m'avez envoyé des super choses donc
en retard mais elle va sortir
probablement cette semaine je vais être
en spectacle en suisse le 21 et 22
octobre à lausanne
vous avez le lien des remontées dans la
description il ya toutes les dates de
tournée dessus mais vraiment toute la
tournée jusqu'à mars avril
si je suis pas dans votre ville on va
rajouter des dates rassurez vous mais
n'hésitez pas à réserver par exemple
pour lille pour mulhouse et pour lyon
sapa
assez vite et je vous rappelle qu'à
chaque fin de spectacle on se rencontre
on prend le temps ensemble je prends
vraiment du temps y'a pas de soucis et
c'est parce que ça me fait vraiment
plaisir à moi aussi à chaque fois et
enfin pour ceux qui sont vraiment rester
aussi loin de la vidéo la petite info
exclu pour vous tout en vous parlant de
livres je vais vous le dire
ça fait quelques temps j'ai décidé
d'écrire un livre qui sortira je sais
pas quand je ne sais pas comment j'avais
parlé une fois dans la faq je sais pas
comment ça va se passer mais on va bien
trouver un chemin pour ça et
l'importance et de l'écrire et il ya le
nanowrimo tous les ans si vous
connaissez pas c'est un délire mondial
de personnes qui écrivent je vais le
faire c'est tous les ans au mois de
novembre
comme j'ai passé deux choses à faire
dans une journée je vais me rajouter ça
je vais faire au moins neuf ans je vous
ferai une vidéo est ce sujet là mais je
me lance au moins dans le fait d'essayer
d'écrire quelque chose sortir de sa zone
de confort c'est ça qui est cool
bon je suis en train de faire une
deuxième vidéo dans la vidéo merci
d'avoir gardé jusqu'au bout je vous
souhaite un bon dimanche si vous avez
aimé cette vidéo mettez un pouce en
l'air parce que ça fait plaisir et puis
ça aide à référencer la vidéo dans le
système de youtube et c'est ce genre de
choses qui grâce à vous fait que la
chaîne est de plus en plus visible
n'oubliez pas d'ailleurs de vous abonner
avant de partir ça c'est important et le
mental boxe c'est quoi c'est une vidéo
par jour pendant un an du 1er janvier au
31 décembre on doit être à la 283e vidéo
je crois peut-être 282 en tout cas
rendez vous demain à 17 heures ciao
tout ça
calao
m